[Música]
yo veo poco pero se me escucha bien
ustedes me ven bien bien bueno les
cuento la idea de empezar a
cuestionarnos sobre la comunicación es
porque de alguna manera existe mucha
[Música]
tendencia a mirar la comunicación
como que estuviera en riesgo en base a
que estamos usando permanentemente
pantallas entonces en este sentido vamos
a ver si logro que me responda
situaciones como estas son leídas
demasiado fáciles como que estamos
frente a un apocalipsis de la
comunicación
como que en algún punto nos estamos
comunicando que se ha perdido el diálogo
y que por lo tanto estamos en riesgo
como sociedad
la mirada como terapeuta de la
comunicación que ha transitado
en la ayuda a pacientes que han tenido
problemas de comunicación me obliga a ir
un poquito más allá y un poco la
invitación con ustedes es a eso
no me lleva el apunte esto no sé si lo
tengo bien prendido
a esta se pone en el centro de la escena
como gran amenaza a la pantalla al
celular en sí mismo y se lo subordina al
usuario al teléfono al teléfono celular
y en realidad el celular no es más que
una herramienta entonces yo lo que
quiero recuperar hoy es que miremos al
usuario ese usuario absolutamente
protagonista de la comunicación que es
el que nosotros reconocemos en el
consultorio o en escenarios de
evidencias científicas
la primera mirada es esto me hace
acordar a la señora del reverendo
alegría en los simpson que decía por
favor alguien que se ocupe de los niños
piense en los niños bueno esto es lo
mismo todos los que tenemos hijos que en
los últimos diez años han transitado
entre los 10 y 12 años de edad nos han
dicho en algún momento mamá quiero ser
youtuber y esto porque es porque
básicamente han descubierto que detrás
de la herramienta ellos pueden ser
protagonistas de historias y realidades
y que pueden empoderarse para contarlas
a otros eso antes de las tecnologías era
impensado no teníamos ninguna chance de
que un niño de 10 o 12 años tuviera algo
que comunicar su realidad o su
dificultad y solamente he reducido el
juego si claramente las tecnologías nos
han ayudado a eso estos niños son
hábiles en la estructuración de la
herramienta saben configurar cómo
reducir el gasto de datos como reducir
las posibilidades de la batería cómo
configurar whatsapp de manera eficiente
de hecho nos enseñan a nosotros no es
así
la otra cuestión es esta y en esto me
quiero posicionar como este fenómeno nos
abarca a todos intergeneracional mente
esta evidencia la sacamos de un grupo de
jubilados que estaba haciendo el curso
de aprendo a usar el whatsapp entonces
ella mandó una comunicación está a su
grupo de compañeros su grupo de
compañeros al principio sonrío y después
esperaba una explicación
ella explicó que ella quería ir a la
montaña feliz
claramente esa no es una montaña feliz y
claramente pone en evidencia que si bien
tenemos más medios para comunicar no
estamos exentos de llevar o llegar a
malos entendidos por el contrario
estamos demasiado propensos a eso y eso
no es malo porque detrás de un
malentendido hay una reinversión en la
comunicación
tengo que esperarme para volver a
explicarme y por lo tanto tengo que
transitar a los mismos escenarios
comunicativos o alternar como por
ejemplo con esta cuestión presencial y
todo es posible porque seguimos hablando
de comunicación entonces la idea
es dar vuelta a esta situación en donde
todo es malo donde parecería que todos
nos estamos comunicando
y pensar que la herramienta sirve al
usuario un martillo puede ser muy útil
para clavar un clavo pero si lo uso para
tirarlo a alguien probablemente para
bosque de daño entonces en ese sentido
la idea es mirar qué es lo que nos hace
comunicarnos con esta herramienta
y para eso tenemos que abrir el sol
y mirar un poco más quién es ese usuario
y para eso los invito yo sé que les han
dicho que ya pueden el celular silencian
los saquen los por favor y hagan la
charla conmigo miren su pantalla de chat
por favor
vamos lo hacemos juntos estamos
comunicándonos disculpen las molestias
ocasionadas y estamos trabajando para
usted
abrimos el chat quiero preguntarles que
miren y participen yo les hago una
pregunta si ustedes levantan la pantalla
iluminada pues yo les juro que no veo
nada acá así que me tienen que ayudar a
ustedes de valiéndome los fíjense en sus
10 primeros chats quien tiene chats
anclados arriba que los usa
habitualmente
en 1 2 3 4 5 mil 578 bien vamos de
vuelta quién tiene mensajes recibidos
que no han contestado todavía
dramático estamos en problemas estamos
incomunicados quienes tienen en sus 10
primeros chats personas con las que se
han estado comunicando y se han visto
personalmente en las 20 últimas 24 horas
más evidencia vamos por más quienes
tienen usuarios bloqueados
igual
qué impresionante cuánta estrategia bien
quienes tienen grupos de whatsapp
silenciados
las dos manos no tenemos dos pantallas
bien quiere decir que dentro de nuestras
posibilidades más o menos todos
transitamos la herramienta con algunas
diferencias pero más o menos en lugares
comunes lo que se llama en ciencia
algoritmos ahora los invito a ver sus
emociones en cordobés más frecuentes
revisen los y cuenten me levanté en
pantallas quienes tengan la carita roja
de enojado como frecuente
ahí ver esto es esto qué significa esto
significa que hay normas de uso hay
normas de convivencia yo no puedo
escribir en mayúsculas porque estoy
gritando y usar esa carita denota muchas
cuestiones denota la empatía y los
contactos que yo tengo y habitualmente
y esa carita se puede usar de una madre
a un hijo de un marido una esposa de una
novia un novia etcétera pero básicamente
es un uso selecto fíjense que elevaron
pocas manos bueno ahora los dejo
descansar un rato
bien
la idea que había con respecto a la
comunicación era que yo era comunicador
emisor les mandaba el mensaje de manera
lineal y le transmitía información
hoy el paradigma es otro
el paradigma traza a la idea de rizoma
es decir es una red sin una
direccionalidad determinada y sin un
origen determinado básicamente parece
caótica pero ustedes mismos en este
momento tienen comunicaciones pendientes
e incluso nos están llegando mensajes a
pesar de que estemos en esta
comunicación en el que ustedes
generosamente me escuchan y yo les estoy
dando lata
la otra cuestión es porque nos
comunicamos y porque la comunicación no
estaría en riesgo en la primera cuestión
es mirar cuál fue el origen el origen de
la comunicación es que un bebé cuando
nace tiene una necesidad por ejemplo
tiene hambre y hay un aumento de tensión
interna ese aumento de tensión interna
hace que como necesidad para desplazarla
o eliminarla llore y eso se transforma
en comunicación el primer circuito que
un niño recién nacido realiza ahora bien
después de transitar tantos escenarios
sociales nosotros tenemos todas estas
alternativas para eliminar y diluir
desbloquear esa tensión que tenemos
tenemos necesidades que generan
tensiones y eso nos hace reinvertir en
la comunicación
la otra cuestión si esto me lleve el
apunte es que realmente somos usuarios y
que esos usuarios trazan
el uso de esta herramienta con
estrategia y decisión
yo voy a decir no a éste no le voy a
mandar un whatsapp de texto lo voy a
mandar y no le voy a poner ninguna hemos
y para que no parezca que estoy
relajándome bastante no es para ser yo
no estoy le voy a mandar un mensaje de
audio de tres minutos que mi hijo no va
a escuchar por ejemplo pero que en
realidad me expone en mucho en esta
cuestión de decidir cómo me comunico
anticiparme definir estrategias y esa
aduana tiene que ver con tres pasos a
priori que podemos definir que son la
idea de jerarquizar de valorar y de
integrar
y si esto me llevará el apunte
jerarquizaría la información más grande
más chica y más chica valorar saldría
una información de esta diapositiva y
aparecería en la otra como relevante e
integrar dos informaciones precedentes
generarían una información superador
la idea entonces que la virtud de esta
herramienta la define el usuario no
podemos pensar
que lo que hemos visto en las redes
sociales este fin de semana en relación
a prendas y las movilizaciones del
cambio climático que atraviesan
intergeneracional mente no hacen de un
usuario a experto en estas tecnologías
para comprobar que hay evidencias
colectivas de que nos gusta sumarnos a
qué empatizamos en ese colectivo que la
comunicación es propicia
la idea de te mando un meme o un sticker
aunemos y yo te mando una frase de
benedetti cuando no lo leí nunca o
galliano así que en realidad ya no
transmitamos información sino mandemos
información con sentido mandemos
mensajes
y por tanto creo que estamos en una zona
y tiempo de oportunidades que claramente
nos define como ciudadanos de una época
en la que no es una era de ausentes
presentes sino que tienen clara
convicción de que herramientas quieren
usar para resolver las dificultades
que también involucra a la idea de que
comunicándome me identifico y pertenezco
a un colectivo determinado y hay una
frase muy linda de los del luthier que
la vamos a recrear como para cerrar esto
no todo tiempo pasado fue mejor solo fue
anterior muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
a
[Música]